there you go
that's enough today we are going to be
wearing high fashioned jock straps for
the whole day
hell no I never wore a jock strap before
ice the box though I know war cup and
nothing you know I mean I've never seen
people where jock straps for fashion I
imagine I'm going to look like a hairy
stripper okay
oh my god so small
[Music]
honestly like I like the colors
I feel like this is the jock shaft
Captain America would wear the jock
straps that I wore for [ __ ] for just
plain white and there was a big plastic
cup in the front this is nothing like
that this is a mankini from my weenie I
don't see myself as a sexy person you do
what I'm saying so looking at this is
like this is really uncomfortable it's
like a chin strap hello okay naked oh my
god it's just so uncomfortable I feel
exposed my food was out the only thing
that's on my mind right now is there's a
small like bag holding my testicles you
know I think it's interesting to think
that women wear stuff like this all the
time like really revealing underwear
thongs all that stuff it's gonna be
really strange wearing this jockstrap
under my clothes even though no one can
see it this is gonna be a mental journey
through my own comfort level with my own
body very uncomfortable people keep
asking me it was wrong with me he's like
a baby try wearing a thong I just went
to Staples you know I don't really ever
go commando but I think this is a pretty
similar feeling there's nothing in the
back separating my butt cheeks and my
jeans
and it feels really nice actually I'm
about to go show my girlfriend she's
gonna die laughs I had to change out of
my work clothes into my gym clothes in
the locker room and I felt really
self-conscious because I was wearing the
jock strap obviously and I didn't want
other guys in the gym to see me you know
and it made me realize it's kind of
[ __ ] that I would judge someone you
know if I saw a guy wearing that at the
gym you know where it are the [ __ ] you
want more power to you Who am I to judge
I'm kind of used to this jockstrap
insofar as you use the bathroom without
taking it off all right so the 24 hours
of wearing the high fashioned jockstrap
is over and I actually really liked it
it was very comfortable
this was a wonderful exercise in body
confidence I learned that I still have a
lot of insecurities about my body about
my masculinity if I was completely
confident and secure in who I am as a
person I should have been able to wear
that and not cared at all if you've got
the confidence to rock a jockstrap go
for it I might learn something
[Music]